peace be with you welcome to the dean
show subscriber if you haven't already
i got a former methodist minister
and somebody also who is on the ground
hearing a lot
about the first-hand accounts of a lot
of the
islamophobic rhetoric that's happening
and the harm that's coming to the
communities
in texas he has a great story for us to
share
here in the dean show don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
this is
who was what army army what's different
sounds like who yeah that's the same but
the marines are better than the army i
always have been
yeah so you were a former marine for
mourinho yeah
and now some of the things you sold out
man you became a muslim you wanted them
no i've been called a traitor yeah i had
a when i was a new muslim i had a friend
of mine
that i used to talk to and he actually
called me a traitor after became a
muslim now how the heck
i was gonna say well how the hell i
think somebody called you a traitor
traitor what what
because because if somebody drives honda
is he a trader to the us
or toyota well i mean it doesn't matter
it's a better car right right
see you understand this but most people
don't he thought that it made me
one of those you know al qaeda you know
bad guys by becoming a muslim he didn't
he didn't understand what islam means
and that those people are not true
mothers they call themselves muslims
all right but let's hold up you know
there there are in the news
you know people who maybe have brownie
with a muslim maybe he's muslim not
whatever the case
and uh and you have some muslims who
have some extreme
ideas what do you got to say about that
you know
part of islam is moderation and our
brothers who are brothers in islam
it's up to us it's our duty as i hate
this term moderate muslims
either you're a muslim or you're not you
know if you're not inherited
then you're not but it's our it's our
duty to take the guys who have aberrant
views
and bring them back into the fold as
well we don't reject them just out of
ignorance or unkindness but it's all up
to all muslims to get those people who
might be a little
out there on the fringes and educate
them just make them better yeah so our
our our thing is to to help everybody be
on that moderate
of course but we're not modified muslims
exactly right
so islam condemns all acts of violence
definitely and you now
actually got to see this coming from a
background first
before you even got to see this of a
methodist your father was a pastor yeah
my father you have this patcher and i
was a methodist minister at one point
amazing tell us about that oh wow uh
you know young brother grew up in a
church mother was very active in the
church
and you know i felt that calling you
know from god one day
you know went down got baptized and
stuff and i had that gift that god had
given me to speak to people
and so i started uh learning i went to
uh we call it training school in the
methodist church
you know to a college learn how to be a
pastor like a team like we do in our
religion and and you know started
standing from the congregation
and you know given the word of people
jesus living that life
jesus saved jesus saves exactly that was
the motto now
that's what we love i mean when i say
that i mean look every messenger that
the creator sent including jesus
he was sent to save people from the
hellfire correct we love you
yeah now you said esau i mean this he
never i mean obviously spoke english
english language didn't exist so he
wouldn't hurt know the term uh uh
jesus christ so in aramaic or in a
semitic language it would be isa
all right so the same jesus jesus yes
yeah uh tell us so you were
but but there's a difference between the
save from the islamic perspective
endlessly yes from the uh explain that
to our audience
in christianity they believe that if you
believe in
uh the savior jesus that you're washing
his blood
uh and if you believe in him all your
sins are forgiven
it's the theory of intercession that
there's someone between you and god that
can
by his deeds wash away all your sins
and so by believing in jesus and living
as jesus would
at that point you have uh the ability to
go to heaven
now were you telling people look if you
don't accept jesus as your lord and
savior you're gonna go to hell fire
you know in the method church that's one
thing we don't really say but it's
it's an unspoken thing you know they
tell you the right way and they say the
other way is the wrong way and you know
what the consequences are
so it's not so blatant as you know
you know some people say hey if you
don't believe in jesus you're gonna burn
yeah
not not that blatant but the bar what
the people know
they know that you believe in jesus no
jesus is the way the light
the truth and those sort of thing and
the opposite is
hell yes now how your family also
your dad your father is probably you
know uh very elated to see you coming
and following his footsteps because he
was uh a minister before you yeah
i come from a family of ministers family
your whole family
i have uncles several that were very
well known
on the baptist side of a ministry than
my father
you know were you related to td jakes no
not at all no not at all you know tdj
yeah i know
richard t.d jake says yes he's real big
in that part of the country yeah were
you like uh preaching with him
no no no just you know some the the
uh path i was from in the christian
church is called christian methodist
episcopal yeah
it's related to the old ame african
methodist episcopal church they just
changed the african the christians they
got more modernized
and it's a very moderate brand of
christianity if you want to say anything
it's not very
it's not like you know the back there's
no hell fire and damnation that sort of
thing but it's not
very little either it's kind of that
middle middle ground so
all right we're going to take a break
and we got a lot more to talk about very
interesting uh individual with an
interesting story don't go anywhere
we have a lot more to talk about here in
the dean she'll be right back if you
haven't
subscribe right now
welcome back to the dean show and very
interesting story so your whole family
are preachers yeah uncles
couple cousins you know ministers
ministers and farmers
ministers and what farmers what farmers
farmers yep raising cattle you know
growing stuff
that's a good old boy now small town
east texas
yeah so i mean uh
usually you think of some of these rural
areas and you got like kkk out there and
uh
you know that's interesting about that
my mother was the first black teacher in
all white school districts
yeah yeah she has her own whole story
wow it was the kind of place i don't
know if you know texas all
uh the town next to us the biggest town
was called greenville texas
and they were famous for a long time
having a sign on the highway that said
the blackest land the whitest people so
that was kind of the
i mean even when i was a little kid we
still had the colored and white water
fountains
you know black people went in the back
door like with the front door that sort
of thing so
we're going to get to that uh before we
um
get to that tell us i mean father
uncles ministers preachers
how do you what are we going to say you
know i grew up in a church and i had
you know like any child that grows up in
a church you have a certain
view how it's supposed to be and
you know it's a very pure and innocent
form of it
but like anything that man's involved in
sometimes there's politics and things
and that's what really drove me away
from the church
were the political things the
really non-religious things of the on
that behind the behind the doors kind of
thing
that kind of sounded my you know my
intentions on christianity
so how did you become a muslim wow okay
so many years later i
am have lost my relationship with the
church completely i'm not going to
church not doing anything
i had a muslim i always had muslim
friends and we sit down and talk about
what we believed
i always had an issue with the whole
divinity of christ the whole trinity
thing
because i've been to the school and you
sit there and you go okay so i know
about the council of nicea the council
council on these things and how they
were all inventions
and so uh i'm looking for something you
know i had a friend of mine i had
reconnected with and he said you know
brother
he said you're a good guy he said i'm
going to tell you something i'm going to
give you a book
and he just gave one of those basic
beginner islam books
but with my background being military
and chris and i was really afraid of
making that leap so for about a year i
studied
i'm dillon i moved
i found i ran to a brother who went to
the islamic center of irving
he invited me to come to the open hearts
open doors one saturday
and so i went a little skeptical you
know just want to learn i need to talk
to somebody
and uh so i did that and i actually
ended up taking the new muslim class
even though i wasn't a muslim yet
which uh kind of let me know you weren't
a muslim and you were taking now this
class
i needed to learn exactly those little
things you don't know
as a muslim you know about tawheed and
those sort of things
required your mind is open like
apparently mine is open yes okay go
ahead
and so i take the class uh i'm at a
wonderful uh
shake at the ici uh shake issa
a rwandan sheikh that was visiting there
and we would just sit and talk
nobody ever tried to uh sell me on islam
it was just a discussion
about what you believe and you talk and
people say well that's what we believe
and so there was that common ground so
uh
after about a year studying i made about
mind i want to take my shahada this is a
funny story
so i go i call uh the nurse masha to me
make an appointment they said your mom's
not available
so i said okay i'll wait another day so
i make another appointment
with imam ziya from irving and
hirajanaza so i couldn't take my shahada
that day
so i said you know i had been watching
this guy don't know who he is
he's a good speaker noman ali khan on
youtube
and not knowing that he's very well
known in the community because i don't
know the community
so i uh call up institute
and talk to the assistant nina kager and
said hey i'm not a muslim i'm trying to
take my shahadah
i can't find anybody give me my shahada
can i come up there and see the brother
and take my shahada with him
so she makes an appointment this is on a
wednesday
i go up that friday i talk to the
brother for about an hour we discuss
things about why i want to become a
muslim
what i'm doing and i took my shahada uh
four years ago april 19th with brother
nominal econ
wow that that reminds me of a quotation
from the bible
attributed to jesus where he said this
is life eternal that they may you
may know you the only true god and jesus
who you have sent shahada
saying that i bear witness that there's
nothing worthy worship except the only
true god
and muhammad who you have sent as a
final messenger including jesus
moses abraham and all the preceding
messengers who brought the same message
worship the creator not the creation
that's the shahada that you're talking
about that's
what i'm talking about yeah you took
that and that's how you become a muslim
and i've become a muslim
and uh i've been active uh with
community ever since
they're in uh in dallas fort worth i'm
kind of a
machi gypsy i go where they need me i
have a main small masjid marshall
sahabah i go to
that's my jumaa master where i go to but
i just try to help
other brothers learn about islam um
there's a big uh community in dallas
fort worth of
revert brothers who are all military so
we have our own little association of
muslim revert military guys who served
in the army marine corps navy and stuff
let me get there
they're trying to do uh holy war in
jihad see we got a lot more to talk
about you know
you gotta put this in perspective we'll
be right back with more hindi show don't
go anywhere
if you haven't subscribe right now
back here on the dean show my special
guest
coming from a background of methodist
ministers
and you ended up having an open mind
had some problems with the whole concept
of god being three in one
and the trinity and other politics going
on you like the pure monotheism of islam
of
only worshipping the one who created
jesus moses abraham the one creator the
one god pure monotheism
and all the other things that islam
revolves around islam simply meaning to
submit to the creator not the creation
that's the same like in the lord's
prayer hallowed be thy name
thy will be done that's islam yeah
you mentioned there's many other people
in the military's interesting during the
gulf war
uh you had more over 3 000 u.s troops
come to visit
their station there uh no actually more
than three thousand how many was it in
the gulf war
do you know but three thousand accepted
islam listen 3 000
plus accepted islam anyone with an open
mind like yourself who comes in and
really studies it
seeking the truth they'll see that this
is definitely you know what i'm looking
for islam is simple
military guys like simple things we also
like the discipline of islam
yeah you give your five prayers
everything's laid out and there's no
equivocation islam it's black and white
there's right and wrong
and it's very simple religion and easy
to learn
but now they already i said military
islam oh militia
it's not like that i mean i i think it
takes people
with open minds and some people are
followers of people leaders you know but
if you have open mind and use and you
actually study
islam with somebody with a person of
knowledge
that you see the truth of islam these
things are just so ridiculous
i just i just hate you know because now
we're on the defensive usually
and that's why you have people who are
usually the kkk
type uh racist hater you know people who
who actually have more in common with
isis and these these extreme people who
are not even muslim
who have this hate rhetoric you've seen
people trying to blow up mosques
they'll take me to my next question
because you do some consulting because
of your experience
tell us about this uh here on in
richardson at the
islamic association of north texas just
two weeks ago
we had a group called bear that's their
name they got
because they they saw care they think
cara is an unindicted co-conspirator
from 911 they have all these conspiracy
theories
and what they do is they go protest and
from the masjid
with weapons yeah which to me i think is
a
purely an intimidation tactic now that
being said this is america it's a gun
culture
it's their second human right which we
have no problem with
but i think if you're trying to engage
someone
in a conversation the way not to go
is to show up at the masjid with guns
how about walking on the match and ask
questions one of the guys i debated with
david wright i think is his name he's a
leader of bear and
his whole thing was i need to know
what's going on that monster
come on in and but you won't come in but
we said you know if you want to know
it's a 501c the financial records are
open
instead of standing out here with your
guns on the sidewalk go inside and talk
to their moms
talk to the people now on several
occasions when they've had smaller
groups
when there's been not the group think
mentality but one or two people
people have come in i won't say their
minds have been changed
but they have a different view it's like
they think there's you know insurgent
training going on in the masjid crazy
yeah and the only thing that goes on in
the masjid is training for
for youth to be good people
for people to commit to do dawah to be
called to islam
and you know the other martial about
martial
islam downtown they feed people every
saturday they don't beat muslims
they feed people if you're hungry you
need something to eat
you go there there's no distinction made
yeah
because you know muslims are here to
serve people training the heart
the heart now purifying the heart uh
trying to
better ourselves each and every day to
be better human beings and and
to actually be good neighbors and you're
not being actually as uh you know the
verse in the bible where it talks about
when one came to jesus said oh good
master what good thing can i do that i
may have eternal life and he paradise
jesus said
why are you calling me good there's only
one good and that's god and by the way
that's the god that we worship that
jesus is saying there's only one good
but that's god
and if one wants to enter eternal life
keep the commandments one of the
greatest commandments is to love your
neighbor so if
many of these people who who who are
brothers in humanity the christians
and many are stepping up and showing
kindness we've had
letters from people that have written
the different massages and said
we don't agree with those exactly we
need more of that we need you know
and we publish these letters out and
they say things but these people who
come to the messiah to protest
they have an agenda yes and no matter
what you tell them
it's not going to change their mind
because they have the be-all end-all
piece of knowledge that there has to be
something going on in there
all you have to be bad because one of
you is bad and this guy even said this
he said
we don't want any syrian refugees here
because
one of them might do something so you're
going to condemn a whole group of people
who are escaping the same oppression and
terror that americans don't want
and exclude them from the place that
says give them you're tired
give me your poor give me your huddled
masses on the
off chance that one of them might do
something
and you know my response was so should
we exclude all
white males from movie theaters yeah and
my brother said what's different because
you know the lone shooter is another
crazy guy
and i said well if you flip it around
well let's say the same thing
those people are unaddicted indicative
of you know muslims they're big things
so you can't say
because one guy committed an act in san
bernardino
that now 1.6 billion muslims are all
guilty because of this one guy
one guy and you forgot about the 355
356 parties more now mass uh shootings
that weren't muslim correct you forgot
about that they never bring those up
they don't bring that up yes
yeah so it's crazy uh do you think we're
almost out of time
you mentioned uh your mother uh was it
your mother grandmother that uh
she actually was the first woman yes she
was the first black school teacher
in an all-white school district in east
texas little town
called uh gilmore texas yeah upstairs
school district and uh
my mother's a a good woman a good
christian woman
a lot of my friends ask how can you love
your mother and be a muslim
i go because she's my mother we all know
the hadith right yes
who should you love best your mother
again your mother your mother and
finally your father
and the question my mother asked me when
i became a muslim was do i still believe
in god
and i said yes and she was fine we've
never had an issue since and
and that's the same god that jesus uh
that's the other problem with the people
and the guns they say that our god is
not the same god they say he's the moon
guy and all those sort of things always
rubbish so yeah but you know i look at
like this if
god allah says don't worship the moon
don't worship don't worship anything in
creation worship don't who created
creation
if my mother who has you know
let's say one razor in church still
active in their church can accept
me being a muslim and i can accept her
being a christian and we can get along
i don't see the issue yeah haters are
always going to hate
uh before we go what i wanted to mention
was you had at one point history
in time very evil things happening to
african americans in this country uh you
had to happen into the japanese
right uh you think now we're we're the
scapegoats now
it's uh we are definitely the the latest
i would say another turmoil
on your show but we're definitely the
scapegoats now
the pawns the pawns now that for for a
general homophobia is an industry
industry it's a billion dollar business
and it's
sowing lies hate deceit
to make money for people and you know
it's like you know
i've been you've been the american
public has been bamboozled yeah they've
been hoodwinked the wolves didn't put
over their eyes
so what would you be we got to conclude
but tell us for the person out there
who's tuned in now
that they've been led to the dean show
and maybe they have all of this
brainwashing that's happening they think
in terror and this
all this nonsense you had an open mind
baptist
methodist minister and you accepted
islam uh what would you uh say to this
person today
i'd say get to know your muslim
neighbors as a person not as a muslim
just as a person talk about
your kids your school your work then
work up to the questions about
how is your religion like mine how is
yours different than mine
and you'll find that islam and
christianity are more alike than
different besides
the one thing we know with taheed and
and a trinity
but you know love your neighbor as you
love yourself
you know give them a chance before you
condemn them
and then go forward from that as human
beings we're going to end with the
greeting of jesus
peace be with you we started with peace
we end with peace thank you it was a
pleasure meeting you and talking with
you dear brothers well they come slow
welcome to the bodyguard
and thank you for tuning in and
subscribe if you haven't already peace
that's what it's about having peace with
your creator
the one that jesus called humanity at
his time
people to have peace with and then
you've got peace within yourself
and when you have peace within yourself
you can have peace with your neighbors
and society
but most people who spew this hate they
don't have that peace
a with the creator and then they don't
have it in themselves so they're spewing
hate
so work on the heart that's what needs
to be worked on
because when you truly have this peace
you're not talking about hurting nobody
you're not talking about doing some of
the crazy things that many of these
people are doing
trying to blow up muslims blowing up
mosques and doing all this harm to their
neighbor no this is not what jesus
taught
nor muhammad nor any of the messenger
and surely this is not what the creator
wants you to do
so go ahead and get to know
your muslim neighbor call us if you have
any
questions 1-800-662-islam and help to
make
i don't need the world a better place
but your neighborhoods your communities
but not spewing hate but trying to
develop
understanding so we can go ahead and
live on a footing of love
peace and happiness we'll see you next
time until then peace be with you salon
lake
if you haven't subscribe right now
you